So just reflect a minute: To get to the moon and back again required real
imagination, a goal to be set, but fundamentally, dynamic and
economy-wide interactions between
different actors to fuel investment in
innovation for a common purpose. So there was the challenge—the broad challenge
was at the time the Space Race and
Sputnik. The moon shot was very specific,
but it required many different sectors
to innovate—not just aeronautics. There
was nutrition, and materials—there was
about 12 different sectors. And then what
government did was really transform its
instruments—like procurement and price
schemes and grants—to fuel that bottom-up experimentation. So over 300
projects in order to get to the moon, of
which many failed. So again, that kind of
risk-taking, really shared across many
different actors, but also, you know,
bottom-up experimentation, also in
business, in order to reach a common goal.